i'm very excited about this season's  diary because  we are venturing into  erotica scorpio woman you love nasty  this is my only place to let this out  this diary  how delicious for us he grabbed my naked  body and pulled me close i could feel  just how hard he was what wow just  remember that this is adults only and  just as he was about to wander below my  shorts we were halted by the sound of a  lifeguard whistle no  no  you know she's happily married to a  really great guy  and she meets a super hot irish guy and  she is willing to go there put his head  under my dress between my legs  does he go down on you with a theater oh  i'm getting ideas he was a master at  licking me  i'm so embarrassed almost to season two  salud and all of you for coming back  oh god i went straight for the slim